Hallo, das ist meine neue Frage. Okay, hier
sind meine Fragen. Zuerst ist es eine längere
Frage. Du hast jetzt schon eine Weile Musik gefunden,
also wie war es, deinen
ersten Vertrag zu unterschreiben und natürlich, was
sich in deinem Leben seitdem und
natürlich seit ihrem Erfolg verändert hat  Als ich
meinen ersten Vertrag unterschrieb, ging es um dich,
Tina, danke, und es war ein unglaubliches Gefühl
und ich war sehr aufgeregt, und offensichtlich lief
alles sehr gut, und deshalb
war es ein wirklich guter Tag,
und ich erinnere mich jetzt daran, dass ich es bin.
Ich werde mich immer daran erinnern. Ich weiß, dass es so viele glückliche
Erinnerungen gab, die danach kamen,
denjenigen zu touren, der diese
erstaunlichen Konzerte übrigens nicht gespielt hat. Erfolg, hast
du mehr Erfolg mit Männern oder nicht.
Hier bin ich, ich weiß nicht  Um
ehrlich zu sein, interessiere ich mich nicht wirklich für Männer, also
bemerke ich dich nicht wirklich